como muchas familias sudanesas el safí
Maggie fue separado de su esposa y
detrás de sus hijos en la frontera entre
Sudán y Egipto sus dos hijos mayores
necesitan renovar pasaportes y obtener
un visado por lo que no pudieron entrar
al país su esposa pasó la frontera con
los tres menores
la decisión de mi esposa con las hijas y
los hijos pequeños y la mía de quedarme
aquí con mis hijos mayores aiman y afmed
ambos estudiantes universitarios fue
difícil es una decisión que tomaron la
mayoría de las familias de modo que la
mayoría de la gente que viaja Deja atrás
a quienes tienen complicaciones con el
visado hasta que puedan resolver estas
cuestiones el conflicto que estalló en
Sudán en abril entre el ejército sudanés
y los paramilitares de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido para los servicios
administrativos en el país Además desde
el 10 de junio ejecutó introdujo nuevas
normas y ahora exige visados para todos
los udaces incluso mujeres niños y
ancianos
miles están bloqueados en Sudán y tienen
que esperar semanas para ser atendidos
en el consulado egipcio
la relación de los niños pequeños con su
padre es muy fuerte fue muy difícil
teníamos Esperanza respecto a las
medidas pensábamos que solo esperaríamos
a que se expidiera el visado cuando
llegamos aquí las medidas el visado
resultaron ser más complejas nos hemos
enfadado un poco porque está llevando
más tiempo pero no tenemos otra solución
que esperar desde el inicio del
conflicto unas dos coma cinco millones
de personas tuvieron que abandonar su
hogar y más de
250.000 han cruzado a Egipto Naciones
Unidas llamó a los países vecinos de
Sudán a mantener abiertas sus fronteras